how have distribution deals changed from
when you first began
making films distribution changed a lot
period um we used to make actually
movies that's how our production company
started we used to make movies directly
for distributors
so that was a different um process
then the industry changed a lot and we
basically then we started to do more
like getting
money from investors private investors
and you know make the movie
and then you shop it around and that's
where we're at right now
basically we make the movie then we shop
around see you know who's out there
and also based on your past experience
how you're treated before by other
distributors
um you're kind of like trying to avoid
certain things you know to happen to you
um like what like being screwed
financially
that's a huge one yeah like being
mistreated
by the film by the distributor uh by not
showing you the artwork
of your movie um not
um being able to prove that or at least
be involved in that
having your name is spelled on the back
box
on the dvd cover or vhs or for like
somebody literally they forgot to put
brad's name
on a movie he directed
on the uh dvd cover on the back but you
know the
guy who did the artwork his name was
there but the director
god forbid should be on the box so you
know
talking of abuse and many issues like
that we had a lot happening
to us so uh we're kind of wary and you
know
sometimes you have you deal with uh you
know if
we dealt with various companies some
bigger some
smaller and sometimes you deal with
bigger companies and you think you're
going to be in
better hands but not necessarily because
they deal with like a lot of movies and
sometimes they don't get your movie even
if they are acquired and you know
paid for that and then you struggle
with their promotion department and they
don't get your movie
and they don't put like like say the
laurels from the festivals on the back
cover you fight to
to do that because they want to sell it
as this big blockbuster thing but you
know that people are not going to buy
that because they know
what blockbusters are out there so your
movie it is an indie
you know sci-fi or horror movie and we
want some festivals a word so let's not
be ashamed of that
you know but there are struggles and
sometimes
how you're treated you know as a
filmmakers you know
you don't even get to go inside the
production company the production the
distribution companies office you're
just more like a production assistant
than
kind of like dropping your deliverables
and they don't even want to deal with
you
to pass by the receptionist
uh so you know we had all sorts of um
situations okay maybe we passed by when
we recorded the commentary because we
had to you know
but you kind of treat it and kind of
kept away
so you know we're working on the last
couple of
movies working with wild eye are
releasing and they are um
distributor in new jersey and usually we
don't work
with distributors who are not in la
because we like to meet with them and go
to their office and all that
but we work with them because
they respect the filmmaker more and
that's important to us
they do send us the dvd covers they do
send us a check disk we have input
we make changes uh we discuss
that with them um and that's frankly how
it should be
but it's not all the time so
what about when it comes to streaming
what are some things regarding
distribution deals that filmmakers
should be aware of
you should make sure that
your movie gets on various streaming
avenues nowadays because you have to
although streaming is not generating a
lot of money for distributor or
filmmakers
also it's getting tougher for
independent even independent
distributors and
filmmakers even like let's say amazon
they're trying to put more restrictions
uh about your content like we had to fog
some areas in our move on our last movie
to make sure at least it gets on there
um
streaming services and i wasn't happy at
all being from romania
and you know having dealt with
censorship in the past and that's
something
people don't talk about nowadays i think
we definitely need to address
that we don't need that they're afraid
that they can be sued by
you know parents whose kid clicked on
your movie and they
see whatever because it's a horror movie
you know so you have some violence you
have some nudity whatever
but i don't think because of that i
should
fog or cut scenes from my movie i don't
think it's fair but
in this case it was the only way to get
the movie out there and i
also it it creates um you know some
revenue that we need as in the uh
filmmakers we really need
so that's an issue that um it just
arrives to us
with this movie it didn't happen
but now it happens also
netflix you know when it started
we used to get our movies on netflix
easily once they start to get bigger
they don't accept a lot of
indie movies anymore not just horror
movies
they don't just accept that period so
it's kind of frustrating because they
build their company on movies like ours
like our older movies they're
you know part of their services our
newer movies
aren't and that's just not fair you know
because then they build their business
on small movies like us when you know
studios wouldn't deal with them because
they know who they were
and then they got bigger and bigger and
sure now they make their own productions
they don't care anymore
so you know streaming is important but
it's it's tough they have a lot of
quality control uh like i think
itunes it's very tough about that like
almost too tough
and it's very hard on indie filmmakers
you know because it's
it's a very expensive process to get a
movie on like let's say
itunes because it cost us and the
distributor a lot of money
and i don't know if i would make my
money back if i
you know give it to them necessarily but
just to go through the process to be
accepted it's very expensive
so you know uh streaming it's still kind
of a complicated
issue we still believe in um
you know dvds and blu-rays and
even vhs high-def even came like limited
vhs because
there are a lot of collectors out there
and
a lot of our fans are
collectors and they're supportive and um
frankly that's what generates more money
than
streaming just like physical media still
even if a lot of video stores are closed
and retail stores are closed
at least you know from various um
sites they can buy you know the dvd and
that generates
more money than actually streaming
so with the the fogging of of the things
in the movie are we talking labels
and and brands or this is like male full
frontal or something
yeah it's it's what's fogging uh we had
to fog
is male full front or women full front
not a lot because they didn't have a lot
obviously
but um yeah it's about nudity it's not
about
brands because we wouldn't have that to
begin with that's something i make sure
as a producer we don't have that
um and i i'm very um
kind of nagging the field producers of
all these segments not to have that
and if we would have that we would deal
with that
we would first digitally remove it or
you know do something or have them
reshoot something so that wouldn't even
get there but no for me it's it's
literally we're getting to a state of
censorship
of you know basically somebody we gave
artistic control now he had parts of his
segment fogged so
i'm not happy about that he wasn't the
director wasn't happy about that
because none of us knew that would
happen
but you know he understands obviously he
wants his movie out there
and that happened onions only on
streaming on dvd vhs
we have no problem because a distributor
doesn't care he's very cool otherwise
you know he won't accept in the movie in
the first place he knows
what these movies are and he loves the
genre and he's very cool and supportive
so he's not the one creating
the problem at all he was annoyed to
tell me about
this new thing with amazon so yeah
and it's is it only amazon or the other
as far as i know
right now it's just amazon but
i don't know like it's something very
new
and to be honest with you other
filmmakers we know
uh didn't have this experience yet so
i'm kind of like trying to
almost talk about it so maybe you'll
stop at some point if we bring it up
you know and discuss that this is an
issue that we started to get concerned
with recently because of this movie and
this situation
also i'm not thrilled with you know
piracy in general
because that really um
you know kills us financially and
it's very hard nowadays to make foreign
sales and
everything because of piracy so it's a
major concern and it's something the
industry didn't do anything about for
years
so that's very problematic and i guess
you know big studios
they're you know they lose some money
but they don't care
uh enough about that and even if they
have offices full of lawyers they don't
do anything
but we as independent filmmakers were
really affected
by that because we lose a lot of foreign
sales and
i mean i had to shut down things on
youtube people putting our movie
illegally on youtube many times a
distributor had to do that too
i had to shut down here and there are
some torrent sites but you know i can't
do that every day i can't
chase these things every day or
otherwise i'm not going to make movies
anymore you know i mean i don't have a
room full of lawyers doing that you know
who are
hired on staff paid to do things like
that i just do it myself and
you know it's kind of negative and it's
not something you want to do
every day here and there look i'm going
to do it because
you know we're losing money i don't want
my movie on youtube
who just came out or something for
everybody to watch it for free
when they can just buy a copy or stream
it on various
you know venues that are out there so
yeah
do you send an email to the content
creator first i mean i realize it's your
your ip that they've stolen but do you
try to at least give them one chance
because i find it's interesting people
they'll fight you back on it like no i'm
not taking this down you're like wait a
minute what gives you the right to have
our
i don't deal with people who put it out
there oh you just
i just go to youtube or whoever and just
write them
i have like a literally um a document
already written and i just copy and
paste it and i just send it
they do take it down yeah they are
responsive if you reach out to them
but you have to do it and you don't
always have time to check on youtube see
if your movie is illegally there you
know but sometimes
if you do and i just do it right away
because i just you know have a document
i just copy and paste it and send it
immediately and it usually gets down
because i have
it's my movie i have proofs only unless
you know
my production company or the distributor
you know they're the only entities who
could
do something with it
you